stockholm sweden go on the plane and
stock oh and Al Gore was president and
their landed in in new york and george
bush was president it was an interesting
moment how is it shaped me i think when
i was in sweden i felt that i didn't
always fit in a little bit i mean i
think you know sweetie sweden is a very
interesting place and i think is there a
great place in a lot of ways but it's a
little bit small sometimes i think i was
a little long for
I mean I think people who I mean
sweeteners I guess a lot of Western
European countries is quite you know
quite Americanized so we get all your
television and we'll get all your you
know fashion and stuff like that and I
think what's interesting about about
moving to another country had I moved to
a you know how to move to Somalia from
since I would have you know i would have
gone to the library or gone online and i
would have so researched it and i would
have been much more prepared for the
fact that you know it's a Muslim country
they look different than I do they dress
differently they eat differently
topographies differently and so I think
a lot of people do and i think i did did
it also is when you come to America you
kind of assume that you understand it
you know we look different you know we
look the same and we speak the same
language and we dress the same and then
you realize that there are little subtle
differences you know you date
differently you eat differently sort of
smaller cultural things that that
requesting that i think is a little bit
of shine
you